[Music]
hi everyone my name is Dan Peck I'm a
product manager on the Google container
engine team so I work with container
engine as well as kubernetes and today
I'd like to give you a quick
introduction to container development in
the Google cloud platform I want to show
you how easy it is to write in deploy
code using containers with the various
tools that are available to you on the
Google cloud platform we'll go over
using tools such as Google cloud shell
the Google container registry and of
course we'll also go over container
engine as well the main thing is that
the Google cloud platform has all the
tools available for you to get started
with container development well go over
a google container engine and where it
fits within the overall landscape of the
product offerings across the Google
cloud platform Google container engine
runs open source kubernetes which was
started by Google to manage and
orchestrate containers it's a very
powerful tool and I hope to be
showcasing a lot of that power to you
today I'll also run through an example
in demo of writing a simple application
container izing it will push the image
over to the container registry and we'll
really start running and scaling the
application with Google container engine
after manually building a container and
deploying it which is really simple also
you'll put them on how to use home the
kubernetes package manager to even more
quickly and easily deploy containers for
some of the most common applications
such as WordPress MySQL Redis and many
more and finally as you continue your
journey into container development
hopefully you'll be building more and
more complex applications and as you
start building more of these complex
applications they almost always require
the use of persistent volumes to manage
allocate and bind storage and this needs
to be done the kubernetes way so I'll go
through that as well now if we look at
the various product offerings within the
Google cloud platform this is really
where container engine fits in you know
on the one side with compute engine you
have infrastructure as a service this is
where you allocate you use VMs you
configure your disks you configure
networking and in many ways compute
engine is what many people think about
when they first talked about using cloud
technology container engine is
containers as a service as I mentioned
earlier it runs open source kubernetes
and it's really able to manage and
orchestrate your containers using
kubernetes you no longer you all you
really do as an engineer or a developer
running on container engine as you
manage your pods and you replicate your
pods and you have it you create a
cluster and you manage nodes but you
don't have to manage the underlying VMs
the underlying networking the underlying
storage that you would normally have to
do with compute engine all of that
compute engine stuff is what container
engine takes care of for you and if we
go sort of even further with App Engine
if many of you are familiar with App
Engine App Engine is a further level of
abstraction where you know it's really
convenient as an engineer and a software
developer all you have to think about is
writing code deploying code and
everything else is really taken care of
for you all the scaling so that's kind
of the scale of different products that
we have um in addition you know we also
have products such as cloud functions
which are serverless and that sort of
goes even beyond App Engine in terms of
of abstraction so let's go through
coding the container way so we're gonna
get started by actually writing a simple
application we're gonna containerize it
we're gonna run it in Google container
engine and I'll walk through this first
and then I'll show you a demo of all of
this actually working right so let's
take a look here first we have a simple
server JS file hopefully you know most
of you that are software engineers can
sort of see what this is doing here all
we're really doing is we're listening to
port 8080 and as we get a response into
port 8080 we write hello world it's it's
a nodejs application and normally you
know you'd write code like this and you
type in node space server KS test your
code make sure everything looks good
right but this is really sort of before
containers what we would normally do in
a situation like that right but let's
say we want to containerize this right
and in this example we'll use the docker
container runtime right so for dr the
for that container runtime we need a
docker file and all we've really done
here is we've said well we want to use
node version 4.0 we want to expose port
8080 the the source file the server JSI
talked about before and the command is
we just want to run node space server
Jas
so that's a simple BALCO file and and
the next step it really is well let's go
build a container image so if we're
gonna build a container image around
this and we'll use these docker commands
to
images and then we'll also use docker
commands and the G Cal command to
actually push this image to the to the
Google container registry now the Google
container registry is a managed private
container registry that's run and
operated in the Google cloud platform so
you can use that now there are other
manage private registries out there as
well or you can even set up your own
private registry just for your
organization for the containers that you
may use within your organization as well
so let's actually demo this and I can
show you this working in person right in
the back let's move over to I think this
is number two of the HDMI port here okay
so I'm here I've just logged into the
Google cloud platform this is our
console and so on what we see here is
I've simply logged in I'm using Google
Cloud shell which you can get to simply
by clicking that button there so this is
a shell that's running within the Google
cloud platform it's pretty convenient
this may not be the way that you would
do development on a regular basis like
on a regular basis you'll probably use
your own laptops and you'll run the
kubernetes and the G cloud commands
directly but you know for this demo I'll
use cloud shell and it's and it's very
convenient because if you don't happen
to have your laptop with you or if you
want to have a quick environment up and
running this always this is always there
for you right so I created a directory
here called hello node if we kind of
take a look at this directory I'll take
a look at server j/s and this is a file
that we kind of looked at earlier it's
the same file there and as I did over
there if I type in node space server Jas
now the file is actually all supposed to
be running whenever we have these live
demos we always end up having these kind
of issues
even though let's take a look at server
ojs make sure it looks good
it's always fun Osaka Authority in use
okay so um going so I'm gonna actually
just build this as a dr. container next
and then which basically is this command
so we'll take a look at that dr. command
and I'll actually compile this and run
this so this is a docker file that we
also looked at earlier and we have if we
actually build it
now the doctoral file has actually run
and we've built the docker file itself
I'm gonna actually run this as a docker
container and what you see here is like
the first thing that we do is we
actually ran this as a container there
and the second thing that I do is I
actually curled this and we see the
hello world coming up so it's actually
writing a stack of container we can do
some things here like if you're familiar
doctor we can run docker PS to see
what's running we see that we have hello
tutorial running here I'm going to run
docker like stop
hello tutorial then you know it'll stop
the docker process from running so we
have a couple of things like that that
we can actually do here within the
docker process there right so there you
have it what we've done at this point is
we've taken a program that we wrote the
server dot JS file the simple note that
J's file we've actually containerized it
and we actually ran it in docker so we
ran the curl command so now we know that
hey our code actually works and the
containerized version of our code
actually works so pretty good there but
you know the problem now is I'm you know
running a container and building a
container with docker is it's pretty
easy to do and it's pretty convenient
and doctor gives you a lot of pretty
cool tools there but the next step is if
you want to run this type of container
in a production environment well now we
have to think about a lot of other
things we have to think about how would
you scale this how do you update this
how do we handle rolling updates so that
we plug this into a CI CD type of
framework right and to manage your
containers in that sense this is where
we need kubernetes to come in so this is
what kubernetes can come in and actually
manage and orchestrate our containers
for us right so let's go create so what
I'm gonna do now is I'm actually gonna
create a pod this same pod running the
same image running
except the difference this time is I'm
actually going to run this in kubernetes
and have it managed by kubernetes right
so that's actually all I'm doing here is
I'm actually running this as a node that
I'm creating in kubernetes with that
image and what we see here is I'm
running this as it's the containers
being created right now and if we sort
of keep going up with this we'll see
that hey this is running now that we
have a sink a node running with a single
pod running a single container we have
this hello node you can kind of see here
that it starts with the numbers 4 2 2 2
that's kind of just the the unique name
that we've given that's been assigned to
our node here right the other thing that
I want to do is I'm actually want to
test this using a browser that
externally available so I'm gonna expose
this so what this command here does is
this will basically expose the I'll copy
all of these but this will actually
expose our node through kubernetes to
the outside world so among the other
thing that I also wanted to do here was
I said you know what if I want to add a
little bit of redundancy here a little
bit of replication and I want to make
sure that our pods stay up and running
for a long time so I'm gonna set four
replicas here so in this sense instead
of having one pod running as a single
pod we have we have for running so now
we've scaled this little application a
little bit we've running we're running
in 4 pods we see here that you know out
of the 4 that was one running from
before and we have three more that are
that are running there and if we do like
queue control get pods we'll see that
hey all four of them are running now
right so so now we have this plus a set
up with four pods running let me go
check to see if our IP address is
available yet so what it does here is
the hello node services that I set that
other command that I showed up here this
exposed command says hey I want to
expose my hello node you know but my
node here to the outside world so give
me an external IP address and so it's
just pending now that is no longer
pending we have an external IP address
here so I'm gonna go to that external IP
address you know in another window will
hit port 8080 and hopefully we actually
see our hello world coming up right so
now we actually have our container that
we wrote
that nodejs the simple hello world
container we've containerized it and we
actually have kubernetes managing these
containers now we have four of them
running so so far so good you know looks
like everything is working pretty well
it's replicated so if for whatever
reason a pod were to go down there's
always going to be Cooper nation to keep
trying to get for running if you notice
in that command that I wrote up here
earlier by setting replicate replicas to
four all I've really done here is you
know I didn't mess with the config file
or anything like that they just said hey
I want four replicas running and
kubernetes are smart enough to make sure
that there's always four running and if
you you know we actually of a demo
upstairs called Wacka pod where you know
we have nine of these pods running and
every time you keep trying to whack one
of the moles there it's gonna bring a
pod down but coop neg is gonna keep
trying to keep all nine up and running
so you can see how fast memories is that
continually making sure that your your
pods up and running so here we have bf4
running but let's say you know I want to
make a change right I mean you know
every one that all of us that are in
software don't win knows that hey code
doesn't sort of stay stagnant so we're
gonna go in here we're gonna go server
j/s again this time you know we really
want to say hey I don't really like
hello world I want to actually change
this to something else right so let's
say I change this to hello party people
right so we're all party people here I
hope and so now I change the code there
so not what happens in the case right so
this is really where kubernetes starts
excel right like we've updated our code
what we want to do now is we want to
rebuild our container image we want to
push our container image to the
container registry and then we want to
update our hello node to the new version
of code so I'll do that right now little
click commands to do that you go right
here where we have a doctor build this
command here and then we have this and
then I'll sort of do all that so first
section is we build the image we
actually push the image up this next
command here right here which is a queue
control set image deployment and hello
node set it to the new v2 version of the
container registry image that we just
pushed up so that's the sense what we're
doing there if I get the deployment
it'll say hey there's four up and
running if I do a
get pods yeah we see that hey the four
to two ones were the older pods that we
had earlier now it created these new
pods that start with nine six eight and
slowly it's it it's gonna start
terminating all of the old ones and all
the traffic will basically start moving
to these new nine six eight pods if I
sort of continue with that we see that
hey you know within probably about
thirty seconds or so it's done updating
and if I go back here again
I should see party people with this demo
works correctly and we do so so you can
see how like using containers and
container development especially with
container engine it's a lot quicker and
easier to manage your code in this way
right
think about how you normally go through
a CI CD type of process where maybe
there's you know you have to build with
larger files and larger files have to
get pushed through the system I mean
this is a way where containers are
fairly small they're portable and you're
able to get them through this isn'ta
fairly quickly so let's go back to the
slides right now and I'll show you
another demo in a moment as well but so
okay so the next thing so what we did
right now was actually pretty easy right
I mean it wasn't it wasn't too hard to
do we were able to use a lot of existing
tools to to create a container image we
pushed it up to the registry we're able
to get this stuff to work but you know
what about a lot of the other common
applications that are out there right so
you know let's say you wanted to run you
know WordPress or Redis or MySQL or or
or nginx it's like you know you
shouldn't have to go through kind of the
work that we did to do that right you
should there's there's an open community
of people and kubernetes is an open
source project so one of things we
definitely rely upon is our open source
community to work together to solve
these types of problems ourselves so um
so really what I want to do is um you
know if you remember back to the days
where you're installing software on like
a typical Linux box you you know maybe
at first you had to take a tarball you
had to enter it
you had to try to make it and you know
sometimes we ran into errors like you
know library dependency type errors and
things like that
and it was really annoying and and
really what core the help with that was
[ __ ] managers right like yama napkin
those kind things came out and it made
the installation of software a lot
easier in those boxes now in kubernetes
the container stuff that we sort of
walked through earlier was like hey this
is how you build a container from
scratch but we want to build a package
manager as well so how is the package
manager of kubernetes and it really
makes it easy for you to start up and
build and run containers that are most
common in the marketplace right so so
this is an overview on how home runs
runs a set of files called home charts
and they contain the application
definitions that are necessary for the
helm install so as I mentioned earlier
Hamzah kubernetes package manager makes
it very easy to solve many of the most
common applications the list of
generally available home charts we have
over 50 today and those are the stable
charts that we also have a lot of
incubator charts that are still in
progress so it's a growing list that
we've been talking about and you know
specifically there's one project that
we've been working on that just had that
that's actually getting ready for an
awful release right now right so today
and this is spark right so today users
have had to run big data workloads on
standalone spark servers or they had to
run spark on yarn clusters or they had
to run these on meso sponsors right the
community has been hard at work with
spark integration in kubernetes giving
users the option to run their big data
jobs in kubernetes right so we had spark
running in standalone mode and
kubernetes last year you can manually
launch a spark master you can launch
spark workers and you can do this by
hand but the architecture didn't really
fully integrate with kubernetes for all
of the resource scheduling so the Alpha
that's being ready to be released right
now directly integrates with kubernetes
launches executors via spark driver so
it really scales a lot but our takes
advantage of all the orchestration
management that kubernetes so good at
doing so I mean this is a great first
step to enable Big Data spark workloads
to work on scoober Nettie's and to let
users of Big Data move off of the
isolated clusters that you may have onto
a shared infrastructure with the other
applications that you're running
kubernetes right ultimately we want to
see new things enabled by having the Big
Data closely integrated with modern
micro services based applications all of
these things running in kubernetes so
the community's hard at work that's been
doing and the commune's thats largely
responsible for spark a kubernetes in
hoots developers from all wide range of
companies I mean they're developers from
Palantir Google pepper data Intel Red
Hat Huawei many others so this is like I
said it's off already
very soon if you're interested in trying
this out and if you're a company that
uses a lot of spark and you want to try
running spark on kubernetes go to that
link up there and try downloading it and
play with it because this is really the
way that we start getting applications
running within kubernetes and in
containers and they eventually become
home charts and then the whole community
benefits from that so why should you use
home right so how much easy to use
because much of the work and getting
containers already done for you right so
you know you should use home because
it's really fast it's convenient too
reliable there's no reason to reinvent
the wheel when someone else's are in the
communities already done a lot of that
work for you right and you know because
we're our community if you don't see a
home chart for a piece of software
that's fairly commonplace go build it
you know build one contribute to the
community and now everyone else will
have that home chart available so we've
been emphasizing this whole community
aspect of home a lot and you know just I
think three months ago there are only
like ten charts out there that we're
stable and now there's over 50 so you
know it's really worked in terms of
bringing this community together to help
get containerized applications up and
running so so let's take a quick look
I mean we're gonna do a quick demo on
helm and I'll show you how quickly and
easily we can actually get home up and
running right so it's actually so can we
let me get the command up so that's all
home I'm actually gonna install this by
using home Redis so clear that up so
this is basically the only command that
you need to run so hey believe it or not
like that one command how this command
right here helm installed - - name my
stable Redis is really all we need to do
and Redis is actually installed right
now to kind of prove that I'll do a few
control get pods and we see that our old
hello node is still running up there but
we also have this my Redis node that's
being created right now right so if we
add a little bit that'll come up the
instructions that it came up with here
was
no to get your password do that you know
it says Redis can be read access via
that port and the not your class are
there to connect copy and paste these
things so I'll get my Redis password
since it tells me to run this I'll run
that so run that and there I guess that
gave me my reddest password
yeah the pot itself is now running so it
took you know less than a minute to get
that pot up and running to connect to
your router service as a sort of the
skew control and take go to this so I'll
do that so that is actually connecting
me to my um to Redis that's running and
then to login or to connect to register
through the command line it says to do
this so I'll just follow the
instructions and do that right so we're
actually in a Redis instance right now
to sort of prove that for anyone who is
fairly you know a well versed in Redis
I'll do a couple of quick command chests
all set temp - hey so I'll set temp to
GCP next so I set up a name value so
register for those who you are on where
it's it's a simple noah skilled no
sequel database name value pairs so I
set up a name of temp to have valued gtp
next so if I get the value of temp it
pulls GCP next um it's really what all
it really does up I set a variable like
10 or X - 10 then I can increment it you
know we can keep incrementing it and you
know if I get X you know Wow so it's
stuff like that if I exit out of this
stuff we have Redis up and running so
essentially was trying to prove to you
is that hey we have read is sort of up
and running and we have an actual
instance of Redis up and running and
instead of going through a lot of the
work that we did earlier with with with
building the container instead all I did
here was I did the helm install and that
was really all it took to get this up
and running so if you want to get
started with container development yeah
take your existing applications
you know containerize them and run them
in container engine but if you have if
you want to build a wordpress in
for example quickly just do that do that
in home the various home trucks are
available we can just do a home search
and this list here are all of the
currently stable home charts so you can
kind of see that you know a lot of the
sort of typical applications that you
might want are in there because Alissa
is getting really pretty big you could
also do a search and say hey I want
anything that has the keyboard Redis in
it and it'll give me the this table
charts for Reta so that's essentially
how we use home charts I think we can
move back to the actual present to the
slides again
so that was home so our first hello
world application was pretty easy right
and using home Trotz was pretty easy
it's pretty easy to build a container we
push it up to container registry we ran
it and container engine you know using
home we were able to contain our eyes a
lot of the common applications but as
you start writing more and more
applications and using containers your
application will likely start getting a
lot more complex than kind of the
examples we gave today right inevitably
you'll come across the need where you
need to start sharing data you need to
mount volumes across multiple pods so
this is where purses and volumes comes
in and it didn't want to talk through to
how we use persistent volumes in
kubernetes so let's start with with
identifying the problem that we're
trying to solve so first we have this
basic unit of scheduling kubernetes
which is a pod right so in kubernetes
looking at kubernetes concepts for a
second um you know we had containers
that we built earlier and containers and
kubernetes are organized in pods a pod
consists of one or more containers right
and typically when you have a container
it doesn't actually share its filesystem
with anybody else right so containers
normally don't share their file systems
but you know you have a pod that has
multiple containers in it and when you
start organizing your pods like well one
of the questions I do get sometimes is
well which containers should be inside a
pod and kind of depends on you like if
you want to start sharing things like
you know that's the same network you
want to guarantee that it's gonna be
running on the same node then yeah right
you share these and some examples might
be if you have an engine X container and
then if you're running a PHP application
so you have a PHP container you might
want to combine those two because you're
going to sort of scale them
appropriately at the same time but if
you had like a database container and a
front-end container you may not because
you might
want to scale your databases differently
than the new front end right so um in
this sense you know what so we've looked
at here is that you know pods are
composed of these multiple containers so
it'd be but it would be really nice if
these different containers within a pod
could still share the same volume you
know for speed and for a lot of
different purposes right so the second
thing is that containers are ephemeral
right like we saw when we did the
replications over there that we had for
and whenever I updated code Auto all it
really did was it brought up four new
for new pods and it just killed the old
ones right so these pods are are these
short-lived you know units of work and
imagine if there's like a piece of
storage attached to that right so this
means that if that container crashed or
or the machine is restarted then you end
up losing all of your data right so you
know with the hello world app that we
had we didn't really use data so it
didn't really matter but you know for a
more complex application that uses data
back and forth like this can be a big
problem and you know if you imagine
trying to run you know applications such
as like a stateful type of application
whether it be a database or some other
larger application like that
I mean having your data disappear is
just a non-starter
right like it's not going to work for
what we want to do so those are the
problems and this is where kubernetes
volumes comes in right so at its core a
volume is just a directory that you
could pre populate some data in it and
that's accessible to all the different
containers that are within a pod right
and how that directory comes to be in
the medium that that backs about the
contents what happens after a pods
terminated those are all sort of
implementation details that we'll talk
about but it depends on the type of
volume that and you can configure all of
that and if we look at if you take a
closer look at this like kubernetes the
volume plugins can be largely
categorized into two types so the first
type are the persistent volumes and you
know there's obviously a lot of support
for a lot of different persistent
volumes out there right so these are
storage that outlives a lifecycle of a
pod so in other words like could be
anything from an NFS share that you see
up there could be a cloud provider with
virtual disks so life cycle of this
storage is independent from the
lifecycle of the pod right so if the pod
dies the storage is still alive and so
so that's great so if a pod referencing
one of these volumes is created storage
is made available
inside it's attached it's mounted but
then when the pods terminated volumes
are mounted could be detached but the
data is always still there right so the
key is a data persist so if another pod
comes along reference is the same
storage volume the same mount point then
that storage will still have the data
there so it's pretty convenient be able
to have a persistent data store right
the ephemeral side are what we've been
talking about till now and is what's
used in in in pod city in a lot of
volume today where as soon as the pods
created you create this volume but then
when the pods Alita the volume just
disappears right so it's a juicy scratch
space is chaired space and it's a space
that could be shared between between the
containers in a pod
but it's going to go away so the type of
data that you would put in there is
usually temporary type data so let's
walk through an example to help sort of
clarify a lot of this right so here we
have a pod pod as we said earlier basic
unit a schedule in kubernetes contains
one or more containers and in this case
we have a single container we called it
sleepy container here and that's the
Google container registry image there
it's just a container that kind of
sleeps is really all it does but if we
look at how how to set up storage for
this container well we we configure
storage there right in this case we use
a Google compute engine persistent disk
we called it panda disk and what this
file here assumes is that that disk has
already been procured it's already there
like that dislike supposing like that
this already exists in place and this is
gonna reference it right so it's
referencing it directly right so then
the pod also defines where we should
mount that disk that we saw right so in
this example all we did was just said
hey we want to mount that volume data
that we see up there that pendant is
over to slash data seems pretty trivial
but there's actually a lot going on
under the scenes like one of the
concepts with kubernetes is you know you
have these nodes that are running pods
and so when your pod is X is attached to
node then no kubernetes knows to make an
API call to say hey where is this
persistent disk it attaches that
persistent disk to that node which then
attaches it to your pod now
one of the things that kubernetes also
likes it also can do very well and as a
power of kubernetes is if a node is
having issues then it'll create a new
node and it'll drain off that node and
your pod will get moved to another node
right it automatically sort of handles
all that for you so you don't really
typically most kubernetes developers
don't really care where your your
containers are running as long as it's
running somewhere so in that sense York
and your pod might be moved to a new
node and when it does that kubernetes is
smart enough to automatically detect
that change detach this from the first
node that was having a problem attach it
to this other node and anytime your your
pod sort of moves nodes your volumes
will always follow it and and kubernetes
always know so make sure that it tracks
it and attaches it to node itself so so
there's a lot sort of going on under the
scenes in there right when kubernetes
takes care of this but you know I mean
this is pretty cool and it works but we
can actually do a lot better than this
so and that's really where processor
volumes is persistent volumes is a is is
what kubernetes does to manage volumes
and it's a little bit better than what
we just looked at preserve volumes it's
an abstract storage there that is used
and managed by kubernetes so we have the
way did it sort of describe this is we
have two different roles they could be
the same person within your organization
we have this first role that's a cluster
administrator that creates a number of
persistent volumes that are available so
the admins provisions them and then we
have users that claim the volumes that
they want to you so in some ways it's
similar to how like an admin might
create a cluster with a bunch of nodes
and then users say I want replicas and
pods running and you know they'll
automatically get assigned to the to
these no so in that sense a user says I
need you know say 100 gigabytes and if
there's 100 gigabytes available in any
volume then it'll get assigned to that
right so in static provisioning you know
that's a fairly simple use case in that
if any of if you make a claim and
there's a PV available it'll attach it
to that dynamic provisioning which I'm
going to go into a little more detail
later works through a thing called
storage costs but that's actually pretty
cool because hey we all sort of work and
live in this world of cloud now right
you know does it really make a lot of
sense to sort of pre provision stores
that's available when the ideally what
you would do is a user says I need 100
gigs we don't say hey is
100 Gig volume available for me to
attach this user instead you say well
okay I'm gonna go on get 100 gigs for
you now find the storage for you
somewhere in the cloud and then attach
it right so that's where dynamic
provisioning comes in and and it's a new
sort of unique feature that's within
kubernetes you know we alpha launched it
in 1.2 we beta launched at 1.4 and we're
ready to make this generally available
with 1.6 which is ready to launch in a
few weeks March at the end of March is
when the 1.6 release date is and that's
when dynamic provisioning will be
available as well so um so let's let's
walk through this a little bit so this
is a simple case of static provisioning
release so we start here with a cluster
administrator this is what a Yama file
looks like for the persistent volume you
know we see here that there's two that
they have assigned one is a 10 10 gig
volume there and then we have another
one that's 100 gigs so the cluster
administrator said hey these are the
persons in volumes that I have available
there's two for you right and if you run
that queue control crate command on that
llamó file and then you want to get PP
it says hey these are the two statuses
available so they're not actually
assigned to anybody so you know pretty
straightforward someone basically said
hey I have these two volumes available
for anyone to use right now let's say so
in other words the cluster administrator
creates the person sublimes and makes
them available for use now we have this
user that comes along and the user
creates what we call a persistent volume
claim right this user is saying hey I
have a precision volume claim that I'd
like to have I need a hundred gigs of
storage so this is the claim that
they're making and so you know we have a
couple things here we have the
persistent volume that was assigned to
that llamó here we have a persistent
volume claim that's being made against
that right so the user creates a
persistent volume claim and now if we
sort of look take a step back and look
at what happened well first we ran the
persistent volume it created the two
volumes that we saw next to create the
the persistent volume claim and now if
we do a queue control get Peavey's we
see that hey you know the the claim was
400 gigs so we see that the hundred gig
volume that was created is now bound and
it's claimed by that claim which is
testin as my my PVC so here we've
statically bound the claim together so
if another user comes along with another
claim for a hundred gigs this is not
available to that user at that point
right so the binder works to actually
make that match and you know it's fairly
straightforward if you know if in this
case like you know they need 100 gigs
and it happened to be hundred gigs
available so it was made available there
so now we end up sort of with this happy
state where the user then creates a pod
and in the pod though they they say
which claim that they which claim they
want and I think I have an example of
that yeah mo file as well so and this is
what that what that looks like so the
pod that we had before if you remember
it had that GCE persistent disk that
pended disk so at that point we had to
make this assumption that pended disk
already exists and that has already been
procured and it's already been set up
we've abstracted this now to say well we
don't have to make that assumption
anymore all we're saying is that we have
this PV claim that we want and so we
know that in this other ammo file we had
identified the PV plane to be 100 gigs
and so all we're saying here is I need
that I need I reference the claim so
this part is now referencing the claim
itself and it's no longer referencing
the actual sort of mounted piece of
persistent disk that we needed so this
is a lot better than what we had before
because now we've sort of abstracted
this out you can take this file move it
to any other server and as long as you
know you reference the claim then it'll
at all it'll just find a disk if pended
disk were to go away and get deleted
like all your pods that are referencing
it won't start breaking right in this
case because it can get moved from one
claimed the claim came to move from one
PV to another PV fairly easily so what
we kind of saw here was we have a pod
that referenced that claim the claim is
absolute tied to the persistent volume
and so let the example here is let's say
the pod writes a piece of data so now we
have that little star in that folder up
there because we have a specific piece
of data that was written you know by
that pod through the through the
persistent volume claim to the precision
volume right but now let's get a little
bit interesting here where the user says
well I want to delete the pot don't want
the pot anymore so if the user goes out
and actually deletes this pod well what
happens
well really I mean nothing really
happens in the sense because you know as
I mentioned earlier we have pods and we
have persistent volume claims then we
have persistent volumes the persistent
volume claimed the persistent volume is
still bound together right the the pod
referenced the claim but if the pot is
gone then find there's no reference to
claims but the claim itself is still
tied to the volume so the data doesn't
go away and the claim is still sitting
there we just don't have any pods that
are using that claim right so that's
really what this illustrates is that the
pod may go away but the persistent
volume claim is still sitting there it's
still bound to the same persistent
volume that we had before and the data
is still not lost right and then let's
say a user creates a new pod again and
act and is referencing an you know could
be another pod could be the same pod
that they bring up again as long as it
references that saying my PVC which is a
PV claim then it'll attach the same
piece of persistent volume again so now
we're sort of back to our happy state
again where we were before where you
know the pods where we started pot you
know new pods came up yet the data has
never been lost so that's pretty cool
right and that's really the state that
we have here again right but let's get a
little bit more fancy now and let's
delete the pod so let's say there used
is each pod and let's also say they
usually leave the claim now we have an
issue here right because while the claim
itself is gone so now it's no longer
bound so if we did a queue control get
PV that 100 gig volume that was bound
before is no longer bound anymore so the
data itself is at this point is is
actually deleted so I'm there couple of
ways that we can reclaim data here the
default way is we recycle it I mean
essentially behind the scenes like a
dozen RM - RF of all the data in there
so the data is gone right so from from
that perspective so and then it's gonna
be made available to other other claims
that decide to use that right so that's
essentially what happens to that volume
in that sense so that's really kind of
the static case that we had with static
provisioning of persistent volumes
because volume claims now I did mention
earlier that you know we have dynamic
provisioning right so this is this is
you know it's pretty cool late-breaking
type stuff I mean this is stuff that's
coming out in kubernetes it's generally
available you know in a few weeks and
you know and like I said earlier like
living in the world of cloud like we
shouldn't have to pre provision volumes
anymore right I mean that's something
that maybe we had to do years ago where
you know you had someone that was
setting up these positions of I'm saying
somebody might come along and you know
they might need ten hundred you know
five hundred gigs and I'm just gonna you
know allocate a bunch of available for
my users to use well rather than having
that paradigm like we should be able to
go through and it should be all
on-demand now right like if a user says
they whatever they need you know we
should be able to make API calls to a
cloud storage type of provider and
dynamically you know build a volume and
then attach to that person so um and and
this isn't only cloud like it could work
within an organization that uses NFS
mount like you might have you know like
you might have storage available that
you can then create a mount it create
the right amount of storage available
and then mount it for them like that's
that's fine too even if you're not
within cloud right but you shouldn't
have to like pre provision everything
I'm just in the chance that someone's
gonna ask for it so um that's really
what dynamic provisioning is here to
address right now the key concept with
dynamic provisioning is that uses what's
called the storage pass right so in the
example here we have we set up two
different storage classes we set up a
storage class for slow which is you know
essentially it's a you know sort of
regular disk it's PD standard and in the
case here with the provisioner as we set
it to be a kubernetes io GC EPD so it's
a Google compute engine persistent disk
the parameters type is you know the
parameter section in this file is
essentially it's just like a large sort
of blob name value pair blob that we
just pass on to whoever the provisioner
is so essentially the reason why that's
important is because whether that's
Google compute engine persistent disk or
any other provider though that
parameters section you can put whatever
you want in there depending on whatever
the provider is expecting so if the
writer decides to update their
parameters with some new stuff you can
just add it in there and it'll
automatically be updated there's no need
to update kubernetes or anything like
that and in this case we set up slower
one for that and then we have an SSD on
the bottom which is fast so you know so
essentially the cluster administrator
and and like I said earlier the cluster
administrator and the
user might be the same person there's no
necessarily need for them to be
different but in the example here the
different roles so in this case they've
set up a slow and a fast and you know to
the users that they're telling them hey
if you want storage and you want to
dynamically provision it tell me if you
want you know if you want slow storage
or fast storage right you know if you
and it depends on what what did you need
right if it's maybe if it's like you
know some logging of all the traffic
that's coming in slow is fine right but
if you want something that is gonna
react to loud a lot faster where
performance is much more important maybe
you want something that's fast
but you leave it up to the developer to
set up to to choose that right so that's
what that looks like and with dynamic
provisioning the users now consume
storage the same way that they did
before but instead of instead of in the
claim saying well just how big it is
they add we have this new thing added
that says storage class name and here we
said fast right so if we don't have that
storage class name then it'll just look
for any existing statically statically
assignable persistent volumes but if we
have that storage class name in there
then it's going to look for this in the
storage class portion that we that we
looked at earlier to make sure that
that's there there was a change made
between kubernetes version 1.5 1.6 and
that's why I mean it looks a little bit
different there but you know 1.6 is the
new version and that's where we made
that change to say storage class name
instead of that volume beta storage
class thing that we had before so that's
really how dynamic provisioning works
it's really kind of the next step into
what we're doing with with with volumes
so if this stuff was pretty interesting
to you and I hope it really was please
get involved in the community the slack
channel is up there the github code
repository is over there it's open
source so anybody can go into that code
repository you can download kubernetes
you can try it out you can also be a
contributor as well so you know it's
it's the slack channel especially it's
full of people all day long talking
about kubernetes so you know if that's
your interest and there are a lot of
like-minded folks over there so so it's
a pretty interesting group now also
there it is so there a couple other
talks here hopefully you're signed up
for some of them right after
this talk across the hall Kelsey
Hightower's basically taking this talk
to the next level like you know we
talked about creating a container
building it running it he's talking
about well what would you do if you
wanted to run that container in a
production environment so he talks a lot
about securing that container some of
the namespaces that we want to use
liveness checks to make sure your
containers are always up and running
things like auto scaling your pods so
that you don't have to sit there if you
get a sudden spike of traffic you know
middle of the night you're not getting
paged the the system's auto-scaling
everything for you right so um he's
really talking about how to take your
containers from development which we
talked about into into actual production
there's also some more about like
container engine today as well as
tomorrow as well I think I talked about
this a little bit earlier but upstairs
on the third floor we have wacko pod
real self when we meet the experts up
there if you have any further questions
you can also talk to me at any time as
well again I'm my name is Dan peek and
one of the product managers on the team
and Wacka pots a pretty fun game where
you can play up there where we have nine
pods running as you start whacking each
one the pods go down we basically delete
the pod but kubernetes will keep
bringing them back up again so you can
see that you know it's possible if
you're really fast to bring the whole
ring to bring your application down but
it's usually not down for more than a
second or so as it keeps coming up so um
and the node.js code app that we went
over earlier today at the first part of
this um the link is over there if you
want to take a look at that if you
wanted to run that yourself at home and
play with it in container engine you
know you can always do that it's it's up
I think it's it's it's for you to do if
you wanted to play around with time so
that's really kind of what I wanted to
talk to you all about today I wanted to
make sure I left about 15 minutes or so
for questions so if there are any
questions I'm always happy to take them
hopefully I can answer them but yeah so
there are two mics out there if anyone
has questions or if not you can always
feel free to walk up and talk to me as
well thank you very much
[Music]